AND GAME FIVE
IS UNDERWAY.
THEY CHECK AWAY FROM THEIR
OPPONENT.
SEAN:.
SEAN: A GREAT CHANCE FOR
A TERRIFIC FAST -- TRYING TO USS
BODY.
FLINGS IT OUT IN FRONT BUT
NIEDERREITER HAD IT BLOCKED
WHEN TAMPA BAY ELIMINATED
CAROLINA IN FIVE GAMES ON THEIR
WAY TO THE
SEAN: AND THE GLOVE SAVE MADE  O
THE PLANE.
HE USES TROUBA AS THE SCR
TROCHECK PLEADING HIERE PROBABLE
GOAL OF THE TROCHECK
POST AND
VERY VINCENT TROCHECK, ITIT
AND THE REBOUND.
REBOUND!
A CHANCE FOR NIEDERREITER.
STAAL IS YORK.
THEY TIE THE GAME ATHEN YOU GETA
POWER PLAY, YOU GET TO CHOOSE
THE SIDE OF THAN.
ANOTHER REBOUND THERER CENTERS .
SEBASTIAN AHO WITH THE DRAW.
THE FOLLOW.
SHESTYORKIN.
AND THE REBOUND WASRS ONE OFF T.
AHO.
AND HE MISS PUCK CAME RIGHT ZON.
A STRONG PLAY BY STROME
AND THAT PUCK WE SAW
HAVE IT.
PESCE THROWS IT AT THE NET.
PLAY DROUGHT! DENY
THAT.
SHESTYORKIN IS LATE.
PESCE DOWN LOW!
RIGHT IN THE CREASE!
ANDAHO ALL ALONE OUT IN FRONT.
PUCK
THE PERIOD.
ZIBANEJAD HAS THE EDGE AGAINST
STAAL.
FACE ON THROUGH THE TOP OF THE
SHOW, TROCHECK AND